[Music]  would you tell everybody before you head  it out on the field I told them that  their talent did not belong to them  today was about sharing his wisdom with  the world Lady Gaga and Tom Brady both  crushed this Super Bowl on Sunday form  different reasons obviously but  apparently we should have seen both  pillar performances coming what was it  like being saw us suspended in the air  I've made a decision about a month ago  that I was gonna do it first up The  Simpsons have totally predicted Gaga's  high-flying performance back in 2012  [Music]  so student Oh square root of bomb  oh I love you and as for Tom Brady he  predicted his own a big win in this  commercial for shields health care would  you please remove all jewelry and place  it in the locker oh yeah sure no problem  Tom Brady trust shields MRI you can too  that all actually no I forgot this one  it's kind of new we're gonna need to get  you bigger Locker Roger that  [Music]